hello everyone and welcome back to some
more rapid action unleashes uh last game
we played we were able to win but we had
some lapses in judgment and basically
for the moment I'm living the the Bobby
Fisher quote you know one day you give
your opponent a less and the next game
he gives you one uh but uh it is to be
expected at this level but I'm hoping
some of you that are still learning that
are lower rated are getting some uh
something out of these games and
hopefully my my thought process is
helping you a little bit even though it
is faulty at times uh but um it also
helps me improve and I am really really
starting to like these rapid games it's
um I've tried playing some Blitz
afterwards and it also helps with my
Blitz thought processes I'm making a lot
less um uh silly moves so uh let's dive
straight into it last game we had the
black pieces we won very nicely uh but
now it's time to play a new game so
let's go for 10 minutes per player now
we only allow higher rated opponent so
we'll see who we get to this one uh
sometimes we get two blacks in a row
sometimes we get two whites in a row but
I I think most of the times it's like
one game black one game white so yeah
let's check it out I'm still sticking to
E4 and on U uh on uh on playing Black
sorry what was this he aborted the game
uh liol did not want to play so let's go
for another
one uh all right our next opponent is uh
Bala Bea from Poland all right baa from
Poland let's do this Bea says have fun
you have fun as
well uh my my dear opponent all right so
it's a c he goes for the uh he goes for
the hyper accelerated Dragon the uh the
opening I've been using quite a lot and
while I like Queen captures on D4 I'm
going to stick with the Knight captures
and I'm going to go for the
marozi uh to see how he will play it
against me all right so let's
see and what are some of the moves that
I could be using when I play it all
right so he goes for this uh we're going
to go for we're going to go for Bishop
to E2 castles B3 and F3 so I think
that's uh that's a nice way to do it
let's just go Bishop E2 let's
Castle uh yeah he goes Bishop D7 so he
will go for Knight captures Bishop
captur so he can free up the C6 Square
for his Knight so I could play F3 I
don't know if it's if if it's necessary
here might also be able to do something
like Bishop to F3 as I will be defending
this with
uh let's go King H1
first okay so he he's going to go for it
right away okay we're going to play
F3 uh and A5 okay we're going to play B3
is B3 a problem here since my Rook is
still here yeah I don't think it
is yeah sort of boxed in my uh my light
Square Bishop a little bit but we're
going to we're going to tend to that a
bit a bit later all right so he of
course wants to capture we're going to
capture do we want to capture or do we
want him to capture yeah this is the the
Eternal
question all right so let's uh let's
force him to capture let's play Knight
D5 sort of to gain access to
B6 yeah let's do it like
this
all right so he's playing very quickly
or she uh as uh I don't know who I'm
playing against and now Knight to D5 may
be a bit awkward since I there might
still be moves I could play to improve
my position before making Knight D5 uh
but I just want to want to put the
Knight there I'm saying okay if you
capture I'm going to capture back
nothing really happening there okay and
if he plays E6 he weakens the D6 Pawn is
going to be a fairly weak backwards Pawn
so the Knight here uh the Knight
definitely belongs here uh on on C5 and
uh it's a fine fine Square for the
Knight I'm still not uh eager on
capturing
here maybe E6 now will be a bit
dangerous so we're going to capture now
or do we do we do we want to capture
this yeah the Knight is fairly strong
there
huh yeah let's capture we're going to
capture
and we're going to play Queen
check okay so he goes
E5 uh a move I did not expect but can't
say that I'm unhappy about it yeah let's
go
here and he okay so he wants to get the
D4 Square for his uh for his Knight yeah
seems like a lovely maneuver seems like
a lovely
maneuver yeah I can play F5 because he
just captures F4 because he just
captures
so what do we do about our light Square
Bishop it's not the most amazing piece
to be had
definitely yeah and the Knight will be
just a monster
here
huh yeah that's very
nice I might even have to move back the
Knight now but
okay I will allow him to D4
Square he will play Knight D4 and
probably follow it up with F5 something
like F5 yeah okay so he goes Knight
D4 yeah yeah it's annoying I I I'll give
him that that's definitely
true uh but now can we now play F4 he
can win a pawn but does he want to win a
pawn that's the
question yeah definitely mixed up
something
here
let's go to D3 it's not the
best doesn't doesn't look
great but still okay my knight is on D5
his Knight is on D4 and he can eliminate
my knight whereas I cannot eliminate his
Knight so if he captures could be could
be a good positional decision for him he
will have a knight on a dark square and
I only have a light Square
Bishop so if he doesn't capture I might
even reconsider my my thoughts here and
just go go trade off the Knight yeah
he's going to capture of
course of course let's go here and let's
fight for the C file he'll play Rook C8
of
course if A4 which of course is a move
I'm going to play B4 so that's
not not a problem and I have to worry a
little bit about F5 I don't think I have
to worry a lot since I don't think he
has a way of actually getting anything
on the king side like Queen moves are
ah so it's uh a definitely a difficult
position to play this Knight can remain
on D4 for the rest of the game unless I
figure out a way of how to maybe maybe
give up a rook for the Knight and the
pawn and then maybe go for some Pawn
advances in the future maybe creating a
pass deep on but that's a long way to go
just uh sharing some thoughts
here but all in all his position should
be better if I had the CH if I had the
say something about the position you
know engine wise I would say the engine
rates it maybe at a 1.2 Advantage black
but we're going to check after the game
so once I captures on D5 I'm seeing 1.2
Advantage black will see uh we'll see if
we're
correct unless he has some sort of a
great tactical idea but advancing B5 or
something like not right away but at the
at the moment weakens the C6 square and
then he will have to trade on the C file
out wise I will get uh maybe be able to
get Rook to C6 in uh even at the cost of
a maybe an exchange sacrifice so we'll
see um I really have to see his next
move to to be able to consider the
position more deeply so he will go for
Queen to H4 I'm not sure I understand
this
yeah so the question now is which R
which Rook belongs on the C file and do
I benefit from a queen trade as his
Knight will be an absolute monster
against my my
Bishop
yeah okay let's go
here not really seeing anything for his
uh yeah he will go there we'll go B4 of
course and we will not play A3 since
that gives up the B3 Square for
uh
or his piece and I have to be a little
bit careful about moving the queen from
the second rank as he will have Queen F2
yeah that's also also an issue for
me all right so how do we improve here
is there a
way is there a way let's go no let's not
go that sorry I'm being
silly
yeah not the best not the
best oh yeah I can't even trade along
the C file because at the end of the
trade he always gets that Queen to F2
move in and if I play King here to stop
that he then I might be eligible for
some Forks but okay I I will play
it yeah it looks it looks very dangerous
but I will play it looks incredibly
dangerous CU now he might have some
Knight captures on F3 action here not
right away at some point
maybe yeah he wants to trade he wants to
trade and also put pressure even more
pressure on my
Rook yeah he's really punishing me for
having a terrible Bishop
here uh yeah let's just go here let's
just go back yeah Queen B2 doesn't look
all that impressive I have to I have to
keep an eye on The
Rook uh okay so we'll go here we'll
definitely go here he gets access to E3
we can't go
there okay so we have to concede and
play a lesser end game there's no other
way to do
it
all
right at least we get an active King
from this he is a better uh he's better
here okay so let's go G3 simply to cut
off his King from advancing
further maybe it's yeah could be
premature does leave me with a with a
weak F3
Pawn uh but for the moment I'm not
seeing a way for him to take control of
the C
file if he pushes the B Pawn which is
possible of
course
yeah I can't play A3 I don't think I can
ever play yeah this is
fine this is fine let's go yeah uh F4 is
a move here
right is F4 a
move it would be a move if my knight
wasn't uh on such a if my Bishop wasn't
on such a silly Square okay we're going
to move the bishop
back Bishop not really doing all that
much for the
moment sort of just a threat on
F4 although I don't think it's uh it's
doing
much yeah but if he pushes A3 then he
might have some action against my B4
Pawn also very
dangerous yeah but then uh if he goes
after his Rook will be hanging so he's
going to have to trade first so he goes
F4 of course he goes F4 of course we're
going to challenge the king and
uh what is
this is this
wise is this a free
Pawn Yeah that's a free Pawn he's going
to capture The Rook first but it doesn't
matter we have a check in
between yeah we have a check in
between yeah even though I might have
won a pawn here uh yeah we're going to
deliver a check
first even though I want a pawn his
position is still very strong yeah of
course he goes after the pawn
here ah very strong very strong yeah I
have to defend
it I have to defend it yeah he goes
after this Pawn if I go here I blunder
my Rook so yeah he wins the pawn
back he wins the pawn back that's very
nice
so let's go here no let's not go there
let's not go
there
yeah really struggling to find a move
here let's go all the way now we still
can't do it we need a move prior to this
yeah I'm going to play A3 Now sort of a
just just wasting a move so he plays
Rook captures on H4 I really have
nothing
better yeah let's go here
now
[Music]
yeah very very
strong very strong
player so if he goes here now yeah of
course he can do
that if he pushes B5 which is probably
what he will
do we're going to go Bishop E2 a bishop
D3 and then if he attacks the Pawn again
we can defend it this way yeah that's
sort of a sort of a
plan all right so a minute and 37
seconds against his 4 minutes again we
are struggling uh to be to be fast
but you know it is what it is material
is equal but his Knight is much better
than my Bishop
so yeah probably B5 yeah he's going to
go after it so so I'm going to check the
king once simply to force the king back
to F6 and then we're going to capture
here and create a pass
pawn and now he's going to capture we're
going to move he's going to capture here
which is
fine uh we're going to
capture do we
capture yeah this will be
this will hurt a lot if he does
that yeah I have to start pushing no but
then he just goes Rook
B3 just goes Rook
B3 yeah of course ah y he can connect
with my king very
nice very
nice
H very nice uh yeah okay so we we do get
to play a little bit longer okay if King
captures we just uh win The Rook but
still it could be could be lost because
he has the past a pawn so he's just
going to capture on B4 probably yeah
we're going to go here try to make the
most out of the position but it's not
it's not a lot yeah he he just goes here
as he should yeah we're going to go yeah
there's nothing to try
here just
a very very hard position to
play okay how do we how do we get to the
pawn how do we get to the pawn there's
no
way
uh let's give one check first maybe to
win the G6 Square for our Bishop to
control C2 for the
Knight if he allows
it don't really have anything
better nothing
better so now I can maybe play Rook to
A1 if he gives me the
chance yeah but no we're we're we're
very very low on time okay let's go here
here yeah that's how he'll do it that's
how he'll do
it yeah not much we can do here not much
not much at
all yeah we're going to give one more
check and then uh resign like a
gentleman or do we want to see his
technique no we'll resign as a gentleman
here we'll resign as a gentleman so very
good game baa uh he outplayed me in a
line that I'm uh trying to become better
at so now we'll see what
uh what went wrong here all right so
let's see so we play this uh okay this
is perfectly fine okay uh Bishop E2 yeah
it's considered the best Castle is okay
so everything is fine here uh yeah some
some moves here like Queen D2 Rook C1
Knight C2 I played King H1 very much
playable he went for Bishop to C6 so
those are all very standard ideas B3
Knight D5 okay so Knight D5 may be a bit
premature Rook to B1 is considered uh
sort of a sort of the mve yeah probably
later on to support
B4 but okay Knight C5 I played Bishop
captures captures Queen
D4 Queen back to D2 perfectly fine uh
Knight here okay so yeah Knight to C3
that's the way to do it um I shouldn't
have allowed this trade Bishop for
Knight which uh caused me to suffer yeah
and again Knight A3 don't allow that
Knight to be captur here after capturing
the Knight he just has a superior game
Queen H4 yeah and later on I think he
was just better for the entire game but
we'll see okay so we traded it's fine
still I mean the engine gives like a z z
uh the engine gives like a z0 and where
was that moment where we discussed
during the game when I said black is
like like up plus
1.2 can't remember what moment was it
but it was around this moment so yeah
here okay 0 0 but um yeah G3
F5 sort of captures okay I played Bishop
here yeah now he's now he's on one minus
now I'm one minus 1.2 could be that this
is the position I was talking about yeah
the engine goes even further minus 1.4
as it's going into greater depths so
yeah F4 but f four is is now a draw like
H4 I capture he captures yeah so where
was The crucial mistake King captures on
E5 Rook captures on C1 Rook C3 okay this
is fine H King G King G2 why King G2
King G2 because if he captures the pawn
okay then I go after his pawns okay so
uh should have improved okay so now with
capturing he actually allows me into the
game yeah but not Rook C7 actually Rook
to C8 was the move point being that
after he goes for the pawn I go Rook E8
check ah
okay yeah and now King
E3 uh winning winning material so he
will not be able to play Rook here he
will have to play something and then I
play King E3 yeah that was the that was
The crucial move that I missed so up
until this point it was uh pretty much
okay yeah but after Rook F4 no sorry but
after Rook C7 yeah he's much better with
Rook F4 with Rook H3 it's still a draw
obviously but I have to play Rook F7
yeah I don't know why I played
this yeah laps in judgment yeah but now
now he's completely winning and
uh he he won it very nicely so okay it
was not not that uh much of a problem
with uh misplaying the line I actually
played it precisely but at The crucial
moment where it was time to step up and
find a solution to the position that's
where I fell short
and yeah baa even says I watch your show
regularly so thanks for that Mr baa uh
good game once again uh I will I I will
treasure these moments you know as I'm
also trying to improve in the hyper
accelerated Dragon so I also uh learned
from this game uh but yeah very nice
hope you guys got something out of this
if you're a hyper accelerated Dragon
player or if you struggle playing
against the hyper accelerated Dragon the
the mody bind structure usually works
very well against the hyper accelerator
dragon as you've seen here uh but uh you
know when it's time to fight it's time
to fight uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it we will
continue tomorrow with some more rapid
action until then H have a great day and
you know uh study study study the end
game and uh hopefully you improve your
chest as well uh see you
soon